on a plutôt tendance à se dire que la
France est un pays citadin alors que
dans la réalité c'est un perruque de
ruraux on a 80% de notre territoire 88%
de notre territoire même qui est
concerné par la ruralité
alors les objectifs et de la mission
dont je suis co rapporteur avec Pierre
Morel à l'huissier c'est de partir de du
rapport de l'évaluation des services
publics en ruralité qui a été rendu par
notamment par Jean-Paul Mathey donc qui
est notre président de groupe modem
aujourd'hui et dans lequel ils avaient
dressé 23 propositions sur lesquelles
effectivement aujourd'hui on en a quatre
qui ne sont vraiment pas du tout lancés
on a une proposition qui fonctionne
vraiment très très bien c'est la maison
France service et puis après les autres
propositions ont été engagées
mais ne sont pas forcément tout aboutis
quand on est rapporté dans le cadre du
comité d'évaluation on ne vote paléolois
on analyse les politiques publiques et
l'action gouvernementale donc là on a eu
l'occasion de rencontrer 57 acteurs les
plus diversifiés diversifiés qui soient
de tous les secteurs rural on a tenu
compte également d'une évolution de la
typologie de la ruralité c'est-à-dire
l'Insee a classé maintenant
88% des communes en secteur rural avec
33% de la ça fait que aujourd'hui la
réalité est un élément fondamental de ce
territoire français et elle traversa on
a essayé d'analyser les attentes les
angoisses les difficultés inhérentes au
territoire rural alors la situation des
services publics dans les territoires
ruraux
c'est assez paradoxal parce qu'il y a ce
côté effectivement maison française qui
fonctionne bien c'est-à-dire qu'on
retourne donc les maisons France
services c'est un endroit c'est un
guichet d'accueil dans lesquels on va
retrouver différents partenaires comme
par exemple la CAF la MSA la dgfi alors
là c'est pour la partie trésorerie qui
vont aider à notamment dans toutes les
démarches qui sont au jour du
dématérialisées pour les habitants donc
il y a un vrai accompagnement il y a un
vrai joli succès sur ça et en parallèle
de ça pour autant les territoires auront
toujours cette sensation d'abandon je
pense qu'il y a effectivement un clivage
aussi entre citadins et ruraux on n'a
pas forcément
qui est pas forcément enfin légitime en
plus de ça parce que l'idée est plutôt
de qu'on construise quelque chose tous
ensemble mais c'est vrai que dans notre
imaginaire collectif on plutôt tendance
à se dire que la France est un pays
citadin alors que dans la réalité c'est
un perruque de ruraux on a 80% de notre
territoire 88% de notre territoire même
qui est concerné par la ruralité et ce
qui fait de nous finalement le deuxième
pays
rural juste après l'apologne en Europe
alors ce qu'on va préconiser on est on
est surtout rentré par quatre
thématiques différentes à savoir la
question de la santé la question de la
mobilité la question de l'isolement la
question également de l'accès aux
services publics et la question du
numérique alors on a on a fait un peu
les douze travaux d'Hercule donc on a
développé une douzaine effectivement une
proposition par rapport à ces quatre
grandes thématiques là et qui s'était
propositions qui vont être transverses
elles sont pas forcément figées sur un
seul un seul sujet on a fait donc des
auditions on a depuis le mois d'octobre
on a fait à peu près une dizaine
d'auditions plus des visites de terrain
et donc là on rend notre rapport et le
rapport on va le transmettre
effectivement au ministre et donc avec
nos propositions et l'idée
qu'effectivement ces propositions là de
la même manière qu'elles ont servi à
faire bouger des choses en 2019 ça sert
aussi à continuer de faire bouger les
lignes pour la réalité